les Américains poursuivent leur ligne de
guerre de facto et indirects avec la
Russie ce sont les mots du porte-parole
du Kremlin qui réagit au déplacement de
volodières ski aux États-Unis le
président ukrainien est reparti avec une
promesse américaine la livraison de
missiles patriotes un système de défense
ultra sophistiqué qui permettra de mieux
contrer les frappes russes contre les
civils mais aussi contre les centres
énergétiques bonjour Elena Volochine on
vous retrouve en direct de Kiev la
population salue cette livraison
prochaine
oui bien sûr pour les Ukrainiens c'est
une question de vie ou de mort ici à
Kiev la situation reste encore très
difficile la situation liée au coupure
de courant et les Ukrainiens avec qui
nous parlions dans la rue ce matin
disait que véritablement se déplacement
de volo diverses qui dans une pareille
situation il est historique nous avions
notamment une femme une Ukrainienne qui
nous disait que volo dimirzelenski ne
parlait pas comme un président mais
comme une personne normale qu'il parlait
au nom de tous les ukrainiens et qu'il
exprimait exactement les pensées les
besoins et les sentiments désukrainiens
les Ukrainiens qui ici à Kiev tout comme
dans les régions on prend au combat et
bien se sentent véritablement
victime d'une agression qui vise à les
éliminer parce que les températures en
ce moment on le redit ici en Ukraine
sont négatives c'est l'hiver nous avons
des gens qui n'ont pas ici dans la
capitale ukrainienne d'eau de chauffage
d'électricité on les voit avec leur
bouteilles vides aller en vain à la
fontaine du quartier pour tenter de
prendre de pomper une eau qui n'est tout
simplement pas là parce que le système
l'infrastructure énergétique ukrainienne
et détruite à plus de 50% à travers le
pays ici dans la région de Kiev
seulement 20% des besoins en énergie
sont sont assurés alors les services
communaux et les services d'électricité
travail 24 heures sur 24 pour tenter de
pallier l'urgence mais encore une fois
le système énergétique ukrainien est
aujourd'hui en ruine et avec l'hiver
c'est dramatique alors ils font le lien
direct entre cette promesse de livraison
de missiles qui pourra stopper ces
frappes aériennes ces bombardements et
leur vie quotidienne leur situation leur
survit aussi tout simplement ici en
Ukraine merci pour ces éléments Helena
Volochine en direct de KEF pour France